Bonjour et bonsoir, parce que tu ne parles pas, français, le deux parles allemand. Guten Tag und guten Abend, weil du kein Französisch sprichst, sprechen diese beiden Deutsch im Podcast du Fonds. schöner nicht ausklingen könnte. In unseren Händen. Geht hinten unter, im Meer. La Mer,
La Mer, in der Cote d'Azur. Oui, oui, ja, in unseren Händen. Wir sitzen, wir haben Austerl in unseren Händen, wir schlürfen noch unseren Orangenlikör. Und wir schauen den Rossen dabei zu, wie sie sich aufbäumen, und sich gegenseitig den Garaus machen.
Ja, herrlich, ihr stört überhaupt nicht setzt euch
gerne hin lasst die schule anstuhl derzeit ein stuhl mit polster oder ohne wir haben eine
komplette kalaffe ausziehen die schuhe ausziehen wir haben alle das ist eine barfuss veranstaltung
kommt rein setzt euch hin der pizzaofen wird schon mal heiß gemacht, wir grillen eine Pizza und ein paar Schnecken. Ignoriert noch da hinten den Gong, der da steht, der ist für später. Den wollten wir eigentlich abdecken, aber der kam dann ohne Abdeckung, wurde er geliefert, aber ignoriert ihn bis dahin einfach. Der ist später noch wichtig, bis dahin bitte nicht den Pömpel, genau. Ihr seht hier auch eine Guillotine, haltet euch an der bitte nicht fest, die ist ein bisschen klapprig, die wird auch wie gesagt später noch eine Rolle spielen und ja, deswegen da bitte einfach, haltet euch aus dem linken Teil hier vielleicht einfach fern, ihr seht eine grosse Pauke, ihr seht den Gong und ihr seht noch so einen Pranger, wie gesagt, das ist für die Überraschungsshow von Stefan, ich will gar nicht zu viel sagen, aber Stefan hat ein bisschen was vorbereitet für heute Abend. Und ja, die grosse Säge bitte und den Vorhang. Einfach alles, was da steht. Genau, einfach den ganzen Bereich. Da alles beim Basilikum, alles hinterm Basilikum könnt ihr da einfach ignorieren, weil eigentlich wollten wir es abdecken. Aber ja, schön, dass ihr so zahlreich erschienen seid, falls ihr euch fragt, was das hier ist, das ist eine Vorstellung des Podcasts, wo Podcasts Podcastprojekte ist. Genau, in kleiner Runde heute mal, also nur am Strand, outdoor, für alle, die kommen wollten, Emil ist da, der hat seine Gitarre mitgebracht und hat uns schon was herrliches gesungen, Ah, jetzt trinkt er gerade, kann er gerade nicht sagen, Cheers auf dich, E-Mail, auf dein Talent, Santé. Und ja, er lebt in Frankreich und kam jetzt mal vorbei bei uns in Korsika. Mein Name ist Stéphane Tizze und du bist Florentin Ville. Ich bin mir Florentin Davide. Florentin Davide Pascal Ville. Oui, oui, ich komme aus Den Haag, eingeflogen, ja, komme auch aus der Ecke. Und es wird einfach ein herrlicher Abend. Ich will, dass wir alle miteinander reden, als würden wir uns schon seit 20 Jahren kennen. Also Smalltalk-Verbot, sondern wir wollen direkt wirklich an den Kern. Ich kann mal die Musik anmachen. Es ist Baustellenlärm. Ich hoffe, das ist in Ordnung für euch.
Ich bin neulich in Berlin tatsächlich in so einem Happening-Kunstprojekt-Dadaismus-Quatsch gelandet.
Du meinst den Hauptbahnhof?
Exakt.
Oh, wow.
Gong.
So, dafür war er die ganze Zeit da.
Wie kamst du rein? Warst du im Untergrund? Warst du in der Viktoria-Situation, wo du irgendeine Treppe unten oder warst du in so einem Club drin?
Ich bin an der Volksbühne vorbeigelaufen und das war's. Da war es dann schon passiert. Plötzlich war dann eine Tribüne aufgebaut mit Leuten, die da saßen und dann standen daneben noch Menschen und die haben so jemandem Singenden zugeschaut. Und dann kam aber raus, plötzlich sind alle, die da saßen, auf der Tribüne aufgestanden und zu Instrumenten gegangen. Ah, die sind auch Teil der Aufführung. War es eine Flashmob? Nein, eine Happening-Kunst-Aufführung mitten am ehrlichen Tage. Und alles war ein bisschen seltsam, dann ging eine Frau, die vorher noch gesungen hat mit der Band, ging zu einem Sprecherpult und daneben war etwas anders ausgerichtet, auch so eine Sitz-Podiumsdiskussion-Situation, die haben beide übereinander gesprochen. Ich glaube, ich sollte sagen, hören wir uns eigentlich noch zu, reden wir nicht alle aneinander vorbei. Oder vielleicht hören wir den Frauen auch nicht zu, vielleicht war es auch so eine feministische Geschichte, das habe ich nicht genau verstanden, weil später war sie dann mal in einer Rolle, wo sie über den, weiß ich nicht genau, ich habe es nicht verstanden, ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob es so verstanden werden sollte, es war ein sehr viel durcheinander wurde es passiert es gab eine band es gab einen rapper dann gab es einen dirigenten und dann gab es die tribüne und dann stand die ganze zeit dieses podium mit einem mikrofon wo ich die ganze zeit dachte oder sollen wir da auch hier drangehen soll ich da jetzt hingehen und einen vortrag, habe mich gegenentschieden, aus offensichtlichen Gründen, aber das war wirklich so ein Moment, wo man dann auch niemandem mehr traut. Da war da nämlich auch so ein Stand, genau mitten dieser ganzen Aufmachung war ein Stand und die haben Aperol Spritz verkauft. Ah, okay, und das ist jetzt ah, okay, ich verstehe, das ist jetzt Konsumkritik, das ist, oder kann ich wirklich was trinken? Genau, dann war so, für neun Euro konnte man einen Aperol Spritz kaufen. Ich habe erst mal gelacht, haha, das ist aber teuer für einen Aperol Spritz. Aha, das ist Konsumkultur und Angebot, Nachfrage, Marktwirtschaft. Ah, okay, kann man das nur Kritik, genau. Und dann bin ich da hingegangen und habe dann einen Aperol Spritz gekauft. Aber ist das nicht die Kunst, dass die Realität so wirkt wie Satire auf die Realität? Ist das nicht eigentlich der herrliche Moment, wo es Klick macht? Hat es denn wirklich bei dir Klick gemacht? Ihr habt das Gefühl, ein Funk ist übersprungen. Es hat so oft Klick gemacht in diesem Moment, also wirklich, es hat so oft Klick gemacht. Kann aber auch am Stepptänzer gelegen haben. Also da waren wie gesagt verschiedene Auftritte, die da dabei waren, ja. Ja, das ist so lustig, ein Kumpel von mir hat auch mal eine ganz tolle
Geschichte erlebt wo er auf einem Date mit einer Schauspielerin in einem Theaterstück war und plötzlich war auf der Bühne es war auch so super so brechtes Theater so war also sehr modern sehr der die vierte Wand durchbrechend, postmodern, also es war ja schon weiter, also es bricht ja schon super, so ein bisschen das Publikum ein und die Leute aus dem Publikum stehen auf, du kennst diesen Kram. So, und dann wurde auch die ganze Zeit plötzlich so Klamotten auf so einen Haufen geworfen und das ging dann schon 20 Minuten. Und plötzlich ruft eine Schauspielerin, ich habe mir das Bein verletzt, ich habe mir das Bein verletzt. Und dann ging das Licht an. Und mein Kumpel hat auch, fand das recht schlecht gespielt, auch einfach. Und ich habe mich wirklich verletzt, ich habe mich wirklich verletzt. Und dann ging das Licht an dem Publikum und dann ging so orchestriert, gingen dann alle Türen dann so dann kam hinten noch eine so die intendantin des theaters kam so hat gesagt müssen wir abbrechen ja und mein kumpel dann so ich hasse alles was hier gerade passiert und aber das publikum war teilweise so ist das echt ist das echt ist das echt und es sind aufgestanden manche er natürlich ist auch aus einem Überlegenheitsgedanken heraus so sitzen geblieben und dachte mir, nein, das ist Teil der Show, das ist Teil der Show und dann ging die, sein Date ist dann auch aufgestanden und wollte gehen und er so, ja, Moment, weißt du es nicht besser, du bist doch auch Schauspielerin, du bist doch, oder bist du Teil dieser Inszenierung gerade, also wusste er nicht, war merkwürdig, ja und dann sind sie rausgegangen und das war vorbei, es war anscheinend wirklich dann vorbei einfach. Und er ist dann, hat er erzählt, so eine Woche lang mit so einem merkwürdigen Gefühl durch die Welt gegangen, als ob alles irgendwie, alles spielen schlecht. Moment, ja, das heißt, es war gar nicht gespielt, sondern er dachte, das Stück läuft noch. Es ging eine Woche und dann hat er in der Zeitung gelesen, dass sich eine Schauspielerin, dass er nicht verletzt hat auf der Bühne und alles echt war. Und ich liebe diese Geschichte mit ihm und ich möchte da auch gerne was draus machen, weil ich finde, es hat so John-Malkovich-Charakter. Plötzlich läufst du dann durch die Welt und denkst dir, ist ja alles gerade orchestriert. Ich mag aber auch den Gedanken von ihm, der sagt, ich fall jetzt nicht drauf rein, so wie bei so einer Zaubershow, so, hört doch auf zu klatschen, das ist doch alles so eine Illusion, so der sich wehrt gegen das, was da passiert, aber auch dann irgendwie bricht ein Feuer aus alles und er so, Leute, checkt ihr es nicht, sorry, oh Gott, schau mal, wie schlecht spielt der Feuerwehrmann denn gerade, der jetzt gerade die Leute rausträgt, die billigste, also das ist wirklich noch Postmoderne. Husten, so hustet niemand. Oh Gott, der Rauch, jetzt kommt die Rauchmaschine, so und dann verbrennt er einfach. Und das ist dann einfach, sein letzter Akt war einfach trotz der realen Welt gegenüber, die als Fiktion wahrgenommen wurde. Das ist ein schönes Symbol für alles. Ich finde auch, ich weiß auch noch nicht genau, für was das ein Symbol ist, mit Sicherheit ist es ein schönes. Das sind ja die besten Symbole, wo man einfach nicht weiß genau wofür. Ich möchte ja gerne mit ihm was draus machen. Ich rieche da ein Fiction-Projekt. Ich hätte da richtig Bock drauf. Ich finde das total schön, allein dann da rauszugehen und immer noch zu denken, alle spielen um einen herum. Weil es endet ja nicht. Ja, das ist wichtig, dass hinterher das Stück ein klares Ende hat. Sonst, was weiß man nicht, bin ich jetzt noch die Figur oder nicht? Es gibt ja sogar auch so besondere Gesetze tatsächlich, dass wenn kurz nach einer Theateraufführung der Schauspieler irgendeine Straftat begeht, dass es eine potenzielle Verteidigungslücke gibt, wo man sagt, der war noch nicht aus der Rolle draus, der war noch nicht wirklich wieder Mensch. Ich hasse alles daran. Und dann hat er gerade irgendwie Hamlet gespielt und dann bringt er seinen Onkel um und dann sagt man, nee, nee, das war noch die Hamlet-Figur, die den Onkel umgebracht hat mit dem vergifteten Schwert, das war gar nicht der Schauspieler. Und anscheinend ist eine solche Verteidigung denkbar, weil es da irgendwie besondere Paragraphen gibt. Ich hätte davon auch schon mal gehört, seitdem denke ich mich, ist das wirklich so, ist es ein Urban ein Urban Myth sein. Weil ohne Scheiss, ich finde das so, und das sagt alles darüber aus, wie wir Menschen vergöttern, die auf Bühnen stehen. Es ist so, wie gross man die macht. Und dann, ja klar, er mordet danach, er ist ja wirklich in der Rolle gewesen. Ja, er war verfolgt. Ja, man denkt so, nein, es ist einfach nur, das ist auch ein Job. Das ist ja die, Method Acting, also wie weit geht man, ist man dann da drin? Also ich kenne das ja auch, dass wenn du dann so eine Rolle spielst, du wirklich dann Tage davor dann auch schon wirklich drin bist und dann wirklich so lebst, nur um dann wirklich das nailen zu können. War das nicht Christopher Walken oder so? Irgendwer hat doch gesagt, why don't try acting? Oh, Christopher Walken kann das natürlich auch sagen. Das ist natürlich das Stimmt schon. Einer dieser beiden, die so recht ähnlich sind. Ja, das stimmt schon. Es gibt ja wahrscheinlich auch so Typen in Hollywood, wo man sagt so, ja, das soll so einen Willem Dafoe-Typen spielen, und am Ende spielt es dann der andere, der so
ähnlich ist, so, du brauchst ja so Typen, du hast ja
nur einen Setzkasten aus acht Figuren
oder so, mehr gibt es ja auch nicht. Ja, die grossen
fünf, sagen wir mal,
männlichen Tropen wären ja
der gelbe Power Ranger,
der pinke Power Ranger, der schwarze Power Ranger,
der rote und der blaue,
es gibt keinen grünen Power Ranger.
Und
es gibt fünf Power Ranger. Stefan, Stefan, bleib bei mir, bleib bei mir. Lass die Augen offen, die Augen offen, geh nicht ins Licht, geh nicht ins Licht. Okay. Pink, gelb, blau, rot, schwarz. Du willst mir sagen, es gibt keinen grünen Power Ranger. Aber es gibt ein grün aus der Gummibärchenbande. Es gibt ein grünes Gummibärchen, das hat Erdbeergeschmack, aber der Power Ranger bei Power Ranger gibt es nichts. Erdbeergeschmack? Power Rangers. Es gibt keinen grünen Power Ranger. Also später irgendwann dann, na obwohl, jetzt bin ich mir selber gar nicht mehr so sicher. Das erste Bild, literally was ich sehe, ist hier ein grüner Power Ranger. Du erzählst auch manchmal einfach nur Schwachsinn, aber dann auch immer so überzeugend und mit so oben herab, es gibt keinen grünen Power Ranger, dass man dir auch einfach glaubt. Vermutlich hast du aber auch recht, weil es einfach keinen gibt. Stimmt, ich glaube der, aber nee, die klassischen, die klassischen sind wirklich blau, pink, rot, gelb, schwarz. Ich bin hier bei Power Rangers Super Samurai. Ja, nee, das ist ja Super Samurai, das kannst du ja nicht machen. Ich weiss, ich verwechsel oft alles. Ich meine, mittlerweile gibt es wahrscheinlich alle möglichen Farben und auch lila und irgendwie gestreift und den Mycalf-Aranger und so.
Ich rede ja von der klassischen Urfünf, die ja quasi wiederum, also es gibt ja, viele Leute sagen ja, die Drei ist die eigentliche Zahl, die Dreifaltigkeit Gottes, irgendwie die klassische Dreier-Punchline-Struktur. Ich sage nein, fünf. Der Mensch hat fünf Finger, fünf Mitglieder in der Boyband, fünf Power Ranger, es gibt fünf unterschiedliche Charaktere in der Boyband, lustig, sexy, ehrgeizig, energisch und verrückt. Und eben sexier. Und noch sexier. Und das kannst du sowohl auf die fünf Finger aufteilen. aufteilen dann schauspieler es gibt the hot guy es gibt es gibt den Actionhelden, so Jason Statham-mässig, dann gibt es den Bösewicht, so Udo Kier, Willem Dafoe-haftig, dann gibt es den unschuldigen Protagonisten, so Eddie Redmayne, Tom Holland, Timothy Chalamet, Tobey Maguire, diese Protagonisten, Normalos und die Frau. Leider immer noch, ich habe es nicht ausgesucht, aber so ist es leider immer noch. Es sind die fünf, ja. Fünf ist die eigentliche Zahl, nicht drei. Du hast recht. Fünf ist die Zahl. Ich finde vier ist die Zahl. Du bist bei Simpsons, bei den vier Fingern der Simpsons. Nee, es sind fünf. Es sind fünf Simpsons, es sind vierzig Finger. Es sind vier Simpsons, es sind fünf Simpsons. Ich ziehe ja manchmal abends, wenn ich mir überlege, was schaue ich an, schaue ich dann doch lieber die Simpsons, muss ich sagen. Die Simpsons und Seinfeld. Also klar, das sind die billigen Imitationen, das ist mir schon klar. Aber die waren auch gut. Aber die waren auch gut. Die berühmte vierte Staffel ist Seinfeld. Pokenom gucke ich wirklich auch gerne. Ich weiß, es ist nur ein Lizenzstreit, aber trotzdem ja auch gut. Gut imitiert ist ja manchmal besser als schlecht selber gemacht. Lieber Stefan, sage ich dir jetzt hier, ne? Okay, also was soll ich imitieren? Ist das angekommen? Ja, es ist sehr deutlich. Man darf auch mal kopieren. Ja, okay. Okay? Okay! Da war jetzt zu kopieren! Guck mal, da haben wir ihn doch. Seinfeld. Seinfeld. Seim. Seinfeld. Das ist das Intro. Jemand, der sehr betont sagt, das war rechtlich wichtig. Scrubs. The Scrubs. Scrubs. Ende. Scrubs. Ist es wieder Gamescom? Gehst du hin? Nein! Ich bin selber ganz hyped. Nein, also vor zwei Wochen war Gamescom, aber da war ich nicht. Ach ja, verstrichend. Und ich war dieses Mal tatsächlich, habe ausgesetzt. Du setzt aus und du skippst es? Ich habe dieses Jahr ausgesetzt. Skipp den Scheiss? Skipp den Scheiss? Ich habe es einmal geskippt. Würdest du sagen, skipp den Scheiss? Nein, ich sage auf keinen Fall, skipp den Scheiss. Das war traurig. Ich habe gesehen, wie meine ganzen Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine geile Zeit hatten auf der Gamescom. Und ich durfte mich nicht durch verschwitzte Menschenmengen drängeln. Oh Mensch, und die ganzen Games. Und nein, es ist immer eine schöne, aber anstrengende Zeit, ist ja klar. Es ist natürlich für mich auch geprägt durch die Zeit, als ich dort war und meinen kleinen Zeh gebrochen hatte. Und das war natürlich ein herrlich Vorderfuss-Entlastungsschuh. Gibt es auch einen Vorderfuss-Belastungsschuh? Ja, ich glaube, wenn du deine Füsse trainierst, ja, auf jeden Fall. Ist nicht ein Vorderfuss Entlastungsschuh, ein Hinterfuss Belastungsschuh? Ich glaube, es muss am Ende immer irgendwie aufgeteilt werden. Weil wenn die Last verschwinden kann, dann ist es eine Scheinlast, so zentipitalmäßig. Ja, ich glaube, es geht nur darum, dass man den vorderen Teil nicht knickt. Ich glaube, du musst dann schon das abrollen. Aber tatsächlich hatte ich letztens wieder den Gedanken, fuck, ich habe mein Zeh gebrochen, weil ich habe
meinen linken grossen Zeh nicht mehr gespürt.
Der war immer so eingeschlafen. Was ist mit dir los?
Letzte Woche waren es noch deine Hände? Ich habe wirklich, alles
schläft ein bei mir, die haben alle keinen Bock mehr. Die haben gesagt,
du fühlst nichts mehr, du hast schon so lange
nichts mehr gespürt in deinen Zehen.
Ich habe auch kaum was zu tun mit meinen Zehen.
Also da haben teilweise Leute angerufen, ich dachte mir,
äh, was, wer ist das denn, grosser
Zeh, was spüre ich hier?
Ich bin ein Freund von dem grossen C. Nee, null, keine Ahnung. Kenne ich mit dem grossen, ich bin ein Freund, ich bin ein Freund von dem grossen C. Mit wem? Der wohnt schon, ich komme, der wohnt doch bei ihm. Der ist doch noch hier, ach stimmt, hallo, hallo, und der ist komplett durch, der hat sich abgekapselt und so, wie wenn man lange mit einem Kumpel nicht spricht, irgendwann verlebt man das, bei Körperteilen genauso.. Wenn ein Körperteil lange nicht benutzt, dann baut sich das ab, weil es sagt, ich werde anscheinend ja nicht gebraucht und dann kann ich es ja auch lassen. Wenn die Feinherren den Zeh nicht brauchen. Diese unangenehme, passiv-aggressive. Ganz furchtbar, ganz furchtbar. Aber Frage, macht das nicht was mit dir psychologisch, wenn du den, du hast nämlich gerade das, habe ich das Gefühl, den Kontakt zu den Extremitäten verloren.
Genau, korrekt.
Du wirst zum Floating Head. nicht was mit dir psychologisch, wenn du den, du hast nämlich gerade, habe ich das Gefühl, den Kontakt zu deinen Extremitäten
verloren. Genau, korrekt.
Ich ziehe mich in die Körper,
ich ziehe mich in die Körpermitte
zurück, ich will nur noch in der Körpermitte
existieren, ich hoffe ja noch auf so ein
Kokon. Du bist das Maskottchen.
Ich hoffe ja noch auf so ein Kokon.
Du bist das Freizeitparkmaskottchen, was sich so
reinschieben kann in
sich.
Ein letztes Foto gesehen von so einem Reporter, Lokalreporter in New York, der irgend so was, irgendeine Charity-Veranstaltung von irgendwas, von irgendeinem Kinderheim, sagen wir mal. Und dann war da auch so ein Maskottchen mit einem Dinosaurier von so einem Dinosaurier, der da so rumgewackelt ist und Süßigkeiten verteilt hat an die Kinder. Und dann war so der Timecode und es war so 11. September 2001, 9.11 Uhr. Und du wusstest, in 30 Sekunden schlägt das Flugzeug ein. Und die Caption war nur, there is proof that there is at least one person who witnessed the 9-11 attacks through the eyes of a dinosaur costume und dieser Typ war ein Dinosaurierkostüm und schaut hoch und vielleicht das schrecklichste Ereignis seines Lebens nimmt er durch die pinken Plüschaugen eines Dinosauriers wahr und das verändert schon die Perspektive auf dieses Ereignis. Ich glaube nicht. Also ich glaube, also viel verstörender ist dieser Moment für den unmittelbar neben dem Dinosaurier stehenden Augenzeugen. Wenn du hoch guckst und dann rechts guckst, was ist da passiert und du guckst in die Augen von so einem Plüsch-Dinosaurier. Seltsam. Aus der Sicht des Plüsch-Dinosauriers ist es jetzt zumindest ein schreckliches Ereignis mit normalen Menschen.
Genau, alle schauen erschüttert und traurig, nur einer hat ein riesiges Grenzen im Gesicht dieser grüne, dieser pinke Plüsste Dinosaurier.
Aber ich weiss auch nicht, und da denke ich mir, eigentlich wäre ich lieber der Typ im Dinosaurierkostüm, weil der ist jetzt zurückgezogen, der muss nicht, oh Gott, wie zeige ich jetzt Emotionen oder so.
Du hörst so ein Schluchzen, du hörst dann aus dem Kostüm.
Oder du hast so ein kurzes
Go get them, get the second one, two, was?
Ich freu mir so ein riesenbreites Grinsen, stelle ich mir vor.
Ja.
Und so ein Typ dahinter, der so leise schluchzt.
Ja, absolut.
Aber du kannst dieses Ereignis verarbeiten, wie du willst.
Und so möchte ich auch leben. Ich will in mich hin, ich will eigentlich, dass mein Körper zu einem Kostüm wird und ich sitze dahinter und gucke nur so raus und dann hoffe ich auf eine Kokonbildung, weil die Raupe, die gemeine Raupe, die durch den Wald kreucht, denkt ja auch mein heftlicher Raupenkörper. Die weiss ja nicht, dass sie noch kokoniert und zu einem wunderbaren Schmetter liegt. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,. Aber ich, Made, Raupenmade, bin zu was Größerem bestimmt. Hey, Jerry, du bist, wer du bist. Du musst anfangen, dich selbst lieben zu lernen. Okay? Hey, hey, schau mir in die Augen, schau mir in die Augen. Hey, hey, schau mich. In welches Auge soll ich schauen? Du hast fünfzehn. Glaubst du nicht, ich wäre auch gern die Königin? Was meinst du, wie ich mir schufte, um irgendwie eine Chance habe, aufzusteigen? Aber weisst du was, nein, ich kann nicht aufsteigen. Vielleicht kannst du es. Nein, kann ich nicht, es geht nicht. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind so was größeres Bestimmens. Wie kannst du die Königin gesehen, die sind zwölfmal so gross wie ich, Mann. Die kriegt den ganzen Tag Eier in Eier reingelegt. Ich muss den ganzen Tag irgendwie so Dreck durch die Gegend tragen, ich bin nur eine kleine Drohne. Aber weißt du was, ich kann die beste Drohne sein, die ich sein kann, wenn ich akzeptiere, ich selbst zu sein. Und du, Raupe, du musst auch aufhören, davon zu träumen, irgendwas anderes zu sein. Sei du selbst, sei dir treu, bleib du selbst. Es ist in mir drin eine tiefe Stimme, die sagt, Jerry, du kannst es schaffen, du kannst da rausgehen und du kannst etwas Grosses werden, etwas Wundervolles und weißt du was, ich muss auch nicht immer hier am Boden bleiben. Ich seh mich da oben. Jerry, Moment mal, warum bewegst du dich gerade so langsam? Du bewegst dich immer langsamer. Was ist das für eine Hülle, die plötzlich entsteht um dich rum? Jerry, ich hol dich da raus, ich hol dich da raus! Nein, nein, du musst Lebewohl sagen. Jerry! Du musst Lebewohl sagen. Ich liebe dich. Was? Was ist das? Und so verging ein Sommer und ein Winter, wo Jerry die Made, also Raupe, einkokoniert war und an dieser Fichte hing, an dieser Fichte, wo einst Goethe sich anlehnte und die Idee, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, dann, wir finden den Hinweis, wer kann der Mörder sein, kann der Mörder sein?
Ist es der Nachbar oder ist es der Lehrer? Wir finden die Beweise und sperren dich ein. Niemand weiss, dass ich der Mörder bin, niemand weiss, dass ich dahinter steck, niemand weiss, don, don, don, don, don, don, don, don, don, don, don, don, don, don, don ist auch ein Grund. Ah, okay. Und dann habe ich auch noch so eine Box gefunden mit alten Hörspielkassetten. Nur Bibi Blocksberg, Benjamin Blümchen, wirklich nichts Cooles in Anführungszeichen. Aber das war einfach meine Kindheit. Ich hatte eher so die soften Hörspiele. Was war der Moment, wo du beschlossen hast, die aus deinem Elternhaus mitzunehmen in deine eigene Wohnung? Ja, die habe ich so oft gehört. Das war dann schon, das waren so Dinge, die stehen dann auch ganz lange im Keller von den Eltern und dann irgendwann nimmt man die einfach mit, ohne reinzugucken und so. Und jetzt bin ich an dem Punkt, wo es so viel geworden ist, dass ich es mal ausmiste, weil ich habe auch irgendwie zwei Abi-Bücher aus irgendeinem Grund. Anscheinend hat irgendjemand da draußen, schreibt mich an, kein Abi-Buch. Ich glaube, ich habe irgendjemandem sein Abi-Buch geklaut. Ich glaube, es wurden mehr angedrückt. Auch möglich. Du willst angeschrieben werden, okay. Schreibt mich an, vor allem die Nina aus der Parallelklasse, die ich im Chemie-Grundkurs, die neben mir sass. Also falls du ein, weil dir dein Abi-Buch fehlt, dann ruf gerne mal an. Nina, Nina, Nina, hast du diese Folge das Podcast-Ufo gehört? Nein, ich höre die nicht, ich höre nur Gäste, Liste, Geisterbahn. Florentin spricht von dir, Florentin will. Wer, wer, wer? Kein Grund zu schreien. Sorry, ich hatte gerade noch die Kopfhörer im Ohr. Dieser Herm ist immer so köstlich. Florentin will, aus dem Podcast-Ufo. Moment, da klingelt was. Er sucht dich. Da klingelt was. Er will, dass ich es nicht mehr will. Hallo, Nina. Was, was, was, was? Ich, hast du den Attenhaufen? Hast du den Attenhaufen? Ja, stimmt, an den erinnere ich mich. Ja, der wollte in Chemie immer meine Hausaufgaben abschreiben. Okay, gut, dann haben wir das ja auch einfach Lehre.
Kennst du das, wenn man zu viele Gedanken hat, da war ich nicht, ich war kurz nicht ansprechbar. Ja, aber ich muss ja jetzt viel ausmisten, viel Zeug, und anscheinend war ich ein softer Hörspielhörer, aber es ist kein Problem. Ich war genau wie du.
Fünf Freunde, die softesten, die freundlichsten, die wirklich irgendwie Hachipu, wirklich auch noch bis ins hohe Alter, Hachipu, Benjamin.
Hast du die fünf Freunde gerade als die softesten Weicheier, Idioten, Loser? Von der grossen Triade Fünf Freunde, TKKG und die drei Fragezeichen war immer klar, die drei Fragezeichen für die Raten.
Ich möchte ein Battle Royale von Tiger Team, fünf Freunde, TKKG, drei Fragezeichen.
TKKG und drei Fragezeichen. Wer würde gewinnen? Wer sind die krassesten?
Aber die arbeiten als Teams gemeinsam oder jeder für sich?
Battle Royale auf den Tod.
Und wollen wir nicht auch Benjamin Blümchen mit reinschmeissen?
Benjamin Mac Blümchen, soll der nicht auch noch mit rein? Benjamin Blümchen ist ein Elefant, der hat von sich auch schon mal einen Vorteil. Ja, aber gegen drei Jugendliche? Also die fünf Freunde sind zu fünft. Ich erinnere mich an keinen der fünf Freunde. Es war ein Hund dabei, Stefan. Ah, wer ist da ein Hund dabei? Der zweite ist der Hund. Der zweite ist der Hund. Der zweite ist archiv. Ich weiss auch nicht mehr hundertprozentig, aber ich wollte nur sagen, dass man sich dafür nicht schämen muss, dass man auch softe Hörspiele gern gehört hat, weil es geht ja letzten Endes um die Geschichten und nicht nur um die Gasse, um die Spannung, um die Charaktere, um die Message, um die Moral der Geschichte und ich finde, da haben die auch viel zu bieten. Die drei Geschwister Julian, Dick und Anne verbringen die Sommerferien bei ihrem Onkel Quentin, ihrer Tante Fanny und der Cousine Georgina.
So.
Wer sind die fünf Freunde? Das waren jetzt ganz viele Zahlen, aber keine einzige fünf mit dabei. Wer sind die fünf Freunde? Aber ich sag's wieder, fünf Freunde sind, ist es die Zahl fünf. Es ist immer KKG. Hörspiel. Aber ja genau, drei Fragezeichen sind drei, TKG sind vier, fünf Freunde sind fünf und dann natürlich das Tiger-Team sechs. Und dann die Wolfenbande sieben. Und irgendwann sind sie einfach riesengross. Ja, das Tiger-Team habe ich geliebt, habe ich gerne gehört, da konnte man immer, weiß ich es nicht, da war doch das mit der Lupe oder diesem, da musst du selber Rätseln lösen. warst das einzige Kind, das du das Tiger-Team konsumiert hast. Habe ich geliebt, Thomas Breziner. Ah, mit Tom Turbo, der so fucking gruselig war. Der war so furchteinflößend. Solche Albträume, diese dicken Lippen, diese leeren Augen. Oh Gott. Tiger-Team, seltener Tiger-Team. Moment, nochmal, Tiger-Team, seltener Tiger Team. Moment, nochmal. Tiger Team, seltener Tiger Team mit Minus geschrieben ist ein aus den USA übernommenes Wort, welches ursprünglich eine Gruppe bezeichnet. Das wäre fantastisch. Benjamin Blümchen ist ein Name. dass mittels besonderer Aggressivität oder freundlichen Angriffen, gerade auch für die Angegriffenen, also die ganzen Anführungszeichen helfen, dessen nicht von besonderem Nutzen sein soll, inzwischen hat sich die Bedeutung erweitert. Einer von uns beide hat einen Schlaganfall, weil das hat wirklich überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben. Für mich auch nicht, das ist ein ganz toller Wikipedia-Artikel. Aber ich muss meine Kindheit ausmisten, es muss raus, ich kann jetzt nicht den Rest meines Lebens die Sachen ständig mit mir mitführen. Nein, du musst mal loslassen. Ich muss loslassen, aber die alten Kuscheltiere und die ganzen alten Schulbücher und die ganzen Gruppenfotos. Kuscheltiere habe ich jetzt auch meins behalten. Ja, ich habe einen Mammut und einen Bären, Augustin und Sarotti habe ich und die kommen natürlich mit, das ist klar. Aber jetzt so ein Hase ist jetzt rausgeflogen. Sarotti? Wie kam Sarotti zu seinem Namen? Es war ein herrlicher Tag meiner Kindheit, wo mein Vater und ich zwei Termine hatten, zwei Dinge besucht haben. Wir waren erst im Schokoladenmuseum Sarotti, dann waren wir in einem Naturkundemuseum. Ist Sarotti nicht diese umstrittene Firma? Ja, ich weiss nicht, wie die da aktuell mit umgehen, mit ihrem Maskottchen. Das ist ja der Kuklus, die haben ja so eine ganz ungünstiges Maskottchen, wo du auch denkst, scheiss Problem. Wie heisst denn dein, was ist das nochmal von dir? Also, erster Halt Schokoladenmuseum, um mich mit Schokolade abzufüllen, damit ich still bin für den Rest des Tages. So, das war, denke ich mal, die Strategie meines Vaters. Und danach Naturkunde. Stopp, Biermuseum, wenn dein Vater ruhig ist, deine Mutter im Hintergrund die Fäden zieht. Und dritter Halt Naturkundemuseum, Steinzeit, alte Fossilien, mega geil. Und es gab im im Giftshop gab es ein Mammut-Kuscheltier. So, jetzt haben wir alle Wörter durch. Und jedes Wort einmal gesagt. Das ist ja Punkt, Meilenstein, Podcast, Meilenstein, wir haben alle Wörter jetzt einmal gesagt. Jedes Wort mindestens einmal gesagt. Mammut hat noch gefehlt, tatsächlich. Das ist das Letzte. Und jetzt haben wir alle. Und dann habe ich das Mammutküscheleltier bekommen und habe es in Anbetracht meiner Bauchfüllung mit weicher, weicher Schokolade, Sarotti genannt. Da gab es auch einen Schokoladenbrunnen. Ist das Mammut braun? Das Mammut war braun, ja. Aber ist denn der Name Sarotti auch problematisch oder wo hört es auf? Ja, wo fängt's an, wo hört's auf? Das ist genau
die Frage, worum es hier geht.
Aber da wurde schon was geändert im Logo, ne?
Da wurde schon was geändert.
Ja, viel zu spät, doch viel zu spät.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube der Name ist nicht so,
deren Namen inspirierte vermutlich auch die
spätere Fall des...
Ja.
Der Name Sarotti ist ein bekannter Herkunft. 2004 wurden alle Produkte umfangreich neu gestaltet. Das Maskottchen wich dem Sarotti-Magier der Sinne. Das ist jetzt ein Magier der Sinne. Toll. Statt eines Tabletts oder einer rotblauen Fahne in der Hand wirft die Figur auf einer goldenen Mondsichel Sterne in die Luftft ausserdem hat der magier eine goldene hautfarbe okay also man hat jetzt eine goldene ist es ein magier mit einer goldenen hautfarbe ist natürlich riskant von sarotti sich jetzt auf eine neue hautfarbe festzulegen anstatt einfach zu sagen es ist wie der pringels mann einfach abstrakt weil das natürlich kann natürlich in, wenn natürlich die Aliens kommen, mit goldener Hautfarbe auch wieder zu Problemen führen. Hautfarbe ist generell ein eikles Thema. Ich würde da einfach Abstand von nehmen. Ja, vor allem braucht es das, weil man sich ja einfach entschieden kann für einen schnicken Schriftzug. Naja, aber es ist so ein, ja, du willst natürlich die Tradition auch weiterführen, ne? Also jetzt ist ein Sarotti-Magier der Sinne, primär eigentlich des Geschmackssinns für eine Schokoladenmarke. Ich weiss nicht genau, was der damit in anderen Sinn macht, aber ist Geschmackensinn, ja doch. Na klar, also für dich nicht, du behauptest ja immer, dass du nicht schmeckst. Nicht schmeckst so gut wie nichts, deswegen hat das Schokoladenmuseum für mich auch nur durch die reine Masse Sinn ergeben. Ich habe vor einiger Zeit mal dich als Floating Head beschrieben und genau so entwickelst du dich auch gerade. Also alle Gliedmassen entwickeln sich zurück, deine Hand, alle Hände, alle Hände, alle sind eingeschlafen, alle Füsse eingeschlafen schon und es ist nur eine Frage, bis dein ganzer Arm einschläft. Ich habe mir schon den Zeh gebrochen, Ich bin, also ich stelle mir das Leben. Du schmeckst es von nichts mehr. Ich schmecke nichts mehr. Ich bin wie so ein riesiger Marmorblock. Und der Marmorblock ist ja erstmal unförmig und hässlich anzusehen. Aber der Künstler kann den natürlich bemeißeln und muss von außen alles Unnötige weghämmern, bis die perfekte Statue übrig bleibt. Bei mir ist es auch so, die Zehen müssen weg, von außen, ich will weggefräst werden. Wirklich wie so eine schöne Holzplatte, wo so alles unebene rausgefräst wird. Ich will am Ende, meine Vorstellung ist, ich bin am Ende wirklich so ein Ei, das so eine ganz glatte Oberfläche hat und wirklich so komplett gleichförmig ist. Vielleicht noch so mit so zwei Augen, die da rausgucken, aber ich möchte komplett hermetisch abgeschlossen sein.
Augen brauchst du meiner Meinung nach noch nicht.
Du magst sie ja selber nicht so gern.
Nee, Augen ist nicht mein Ding.
Vor Angst, also du kannst so ein bisschen so eine Nase
oder einen Mund eigentlich noch, ein Mundloch.
Ich habe letztens wirklich bei mir die Situation gehabt,
ich bin ins Bett gegangen und ich habe davor noch gewaschen
und habe, bevor ich ins Bett gegangen bin, noch meine Wäsche
einfach auf den Haufen geschmissen, so, weil ich keinen Bock hatte,
das jetzt alles einzuzutieren.
Und dann lag da so ein Wäschehaufen auf meinem Regal drauf
mit einem Hoodie ganz oben drauf.
Und dann lassen wir es dann Wäschehaufen auf meinem Regal drauf mit einem Hoodie ganz oben drauf. Und dann lag ich im Bett und ich habe so nochmal so geguckt und bin wirklich erschrocken, weil ich dachte, fuck, da steht einer. So, und dann habe ich es wirklich minutenlang nicht geschafft, meinem Gehirn das fucking klarzumachen, dass da niemand ist, weil mein Gehirn war immer wieder so, oh scheiße, oh Vorsicht, Vorsicht, oh oh oh und ich so, alter, das hatten wir doch gerade. Was ist deine konkrete Reaktion? Ich mag diese Momente ja, weil man merkt, man stellt sich ja oft vor, wenn man Actionfilme guckt oder Horrorfilme, man denkt oft, wie würde ich reagieren, wie uncool dieser Charakter, dieser Charakter, der jetzt reingangt ist, ich wäre so viel cool, ich wäre so souverän, ich würde einfach, folgt dem nicht, folgt dem nicht, rennt er nicht da lang. Und das sind die Momente, wo man checkt, wie man reagieren würde. Genau. Die Frage ist, wie hast du reagiert, als du den Hoodie-Mann in deinem Zimmer gewöhnt hast? Ich habe mich aufrecht ins Bett gesetzt. Super Idee. Oh, so, so wirklich aufgestützt mit meinen toten Händen. Entschuldigung? Hallo? Ist da wer? So ist da wer? Und am Ende war es wirklich so, dass ich nach 15 Minuten gesagt habe, ich tue den Hudi jetzt weg. Ja. Ich bin aufgeregt. Und da dachte ich mir, wie dumm bist du denn eigentlich, dass du das nicht hinkriegst, das einfach klarzumachen, hier herrscht einfach keine Gefahr gerade, du Trottel.
So, jetzt kann man aber argumentieren, auch wenn es ein paar Grad zu warm ist oder ein bisschen zu laut ist, man nicht schlafen kann, besteht hier auch keine konkrete Gefahr. Trotzdem möchtest du beide Sachen bitte verändern, damit du schlafen kannst. Das ist für mich immer noch auch so ein Fehler im Körper, dass der nicht einfach sagt, okay, wir haben ein Problem, das können wir gerade nicht ändern.
Ich musste ja leider oft in meiner schrecklichen WG-Zeit oft in einem nassen Bett schlafen und das ist einfach fucking unmöglich.
Du kannst nicht in einem nassen Bett schlafen, geht nicht.
Warum, was war dann immer das Problem?
Da hat die Katze meiner Mitbewohnerin immer aufs Bett gepinkelt und ich hatte irgendwann so ein antibakterielles Spray
und dann musste ich überlegen, will ich jetzt die
Katzenpisse-Geruch haben oder will ich dieses Spray
und dann war alles nass und dann, du kannst
einfach nicht schlafen, wenn die Bette genass ist und
du sagst auch einfach, Körper,
ich weiß, dass das jetzt echt nicht gut ist
gerade, hey, du verdienst was Besseres,
du bist ein toller Körper, du machst viel für mich,
du machst Stoffwechsel, du machst Zellen,
Reproduktion, und wir geben unser Bestes beim Stoffwechsel,
wir machen nicht alles richtig, weil wir geben verdammt noch mal
unser Bestes, ey, ihr seid super, du machst viel für mich. Danke. Du machst Stoffwechsel, du machst Zellen, Reproduktion. Ey, und wir geben unser Bestes beim Stoffwechsel.
Ey, super.
Klar, wir machen nicht alles richtig, weil wir geben verdammt nochmal unser Bestes.
Ey, ihr seid super, du erinnerst mich daran, dass ich was trinken muss, du trägst mich durch die Gegend.
Nein, aber wir tun verdammt nochmal alles dafür, dass ich an die wichtigsten Dinge erinnere.
Ja, und vor allem, du bist mein Körper.
Wie hieß die nochmal, die Buchhändlerin?
Die Nina aus den, ach so, was meinst du jetzt?
Die Buchhändlerin damals aus der Wernerstrasse, wurde immer gekappt. Äh, pff, keine Ahnung. Ja, genau, zum Beispiel meine Mutter hat Geburtstag am, weiss ich nicht. So, unabhängig davon jetzt, du bist einfach mein Körper und ich finde dich klasse, aber jetzt bitte man nur für diese eine Nacht, ich weiss, es ist nass, ich weiss, ja, das haben wir jetzt auch verstanden. Das ist komisch, das ist ein großes Gefühl. Ich weiss, ich weiss, ich weiss, ich weiss. Das liegt da hinten. Aber das wird sich... Türspalt. Das können wir jetzt nur, hör mir kurz zu, wir können das jetzt nicht ändern. Stört ein bisschen. Ich weiss, aber wir können es nicht ändern. Und wir können jetzt entweder die ganze Nacht... Und es riecht immer noch ein bisschen nach Katzenpissen. Wir können uns jetzt entwederweder die ganze Nacht beschweren oder wir schlafen einfach. Nimm mir viel schlimmere Gerüche als Katzenpüssen. Es gibt keine, ich weiss, aber wir können es jetzt gerade nicht ändern. Deine Beschwerden führen zu nichts, okay? Verstehst du gerade? Wie so ein Kind, was Hunger hat, aufs Klo muss, zu kalt, Hunger. Und es ist einfach, es ist jetzt nicht ruhig zu stellen. Aber das checkt der Körper nicht. Das geht einfach nicht. Wo ich mir denke, du musst doch schlafen, du Depp. Aber jetzt so ein Riesenbild von so einem Zombie, so ein furchterregendes Bild, würdest du dir ja auch nicht ins Schlafzimmer hängen. Ja, weil du meinst, der checkt es nicht, dass es kein echter Zombie ist irgendwann. Doch, aber du willst dich ja einfach wohlfühlen. Und ich verstehe diesen Hoodie-Aspekt. Mach dich nicht fertig dafür, dass du diesen Hoodie weglegen wolltest.
Mich hat das geärgert, weil ich dachte, ich habe das jetzt wirklich als intellektuelle Aufgabe gesehen, du bist ein vernunftbegabter Mensch, du kannst Instinkte auch unterdrücken und sagen, hier herrscht gerade einfach keine Gefahr. Aber mein Körper hat gesagt, no way, no way, guy, this is not how we do this here in the Stone Age, guy, because it is not something you can control. Und dann konnte ich da nichts dagegen machen. Ja, ich habe in einem Zimmer geschlafen, wo ein so ein Kleiderspiegel, wo man sich so ganzkörper, so ein ganzkörper Spiegel stand genau, wenn man sich das Bett vorstellt, 90 Grad zum Bett an der Wand. 90 Grad zum Bett. Da, wo ich lag und ich bin morgens aufgewacht, Seitenschläfer, da noch gewesen, hart abdrehen, macht die Augen auf, starre mir entgegen. Das ist auch, und dann sagt Feng Shui, sagt Feng Shui sagt nimm die Spiegel aus dem Schlafzimmer ja und ich verstehe das ist ein guter Punkt ich verstehe das Spiegel haben im Schlafzimmer nichts verloren nicht weil da deine Seele sich vielleicht vielleicht liegt es am Ende. Ich, falls unangenehm, konnte ich genau beschreiben, warum ich es komisch fand, mich anzugucken, während ich aufstehe und die Augen
zum ersten Mal aufschlage am Morgen.
Nein, vielleicht ist meine Seele gefangen.
Kann gut sein. Feng Shui hat da jedenfalls
einen Punkt. Lass das.
Ja, und die Kröte soll aus dem,
eine tote Kröte auf dem Boden
zum Ausgang,
die verscheucht die Geister.
Nee, aber
ist ein guter Punkt.
Definitiv. Es ist wirklich,
dass da noch, es schlaft
Vielen Dank. Die Verhäufe in der Nacht. Nee, aber ist ein guter Punkt. Definitiv. Es ist wirklich, dass da noch Schlafmittel nicht irgendwie weit. Du hast ja gesagt, du willst während der Zugfahrt schlafen, du willst gar nichts mitkriegen, irgendwie du willst ein lebloser Körperleibsack einfach sein, mit dem man machen kann, was man will, bis er dann geweckt wird. Warum das nicht? Wir kommen ein bisschen in so eine Drogenphase, also wir wollen uns immer mehr betäuben, wir wollen immer weniger mitbekommen von der Aussenwelt, auf nahe ist das was wir beschreiben. Aber es ist doch wirklich das Beste, dass du am Flugzeug am, du gehst wirklich in so eine Kammer und dann kommt so pinker Dampf in die Kammer und du wuppsackst zusammen und du wachst auf und bist in Santiago Bay, der Compostela Bay und wachst auf und bist da. Wie geil wäre das? Ja, exakt. Aber es ist ja wirklich, und die könnten ja mehr Leute transportieren. Also es passen ja mehr sedierte Leute rein. Du hast ein paar blaue Flecken, wo du nicht weißt, wo die herkommen, aber das ist ganz egal. Ja, du fühlst dich irgendwie komisch, deine Hose sitzt irgendwie anders als davor. Deine Hose ist offen und man denkt sich, was ist denn hier passiert? Aber letzten Endes müssen wir damit leben, der Tag wird länger. Der Tag wird länger, der Mond nimmt immer mehr Abstand, der Tag wird länger, die Erdrotation verlangsamt sich, die Erde dreht sich immer langsamer, weil der Mond sich entfernt. Wohin? Der Mond hat keinen Bock mehr. Der Mond ist raus. Der Mond hat einen besseren Planeten gefunden, hat jetzt ausguckt und dann sagt, ich will da hin. Und der Mond zieht. Und der Tag wird länger und es kann ein paar, habe ich gelesen, ein paar hunderttausend Jahren hat der Tag 24 Stunden. Wie bitte? Wir haben jetzt 24 Stunden. Genau. Also so eine Minute länger oder? Ja, genau so ein bisschen länger. Er hat dann 25 Stunden. Ich war noch bei 23, ich war noch bei von vor zehn Millionen Jahren, ich denke noch ein bisschen altmodisch, aber er hat dann 25 Stunden und dann ist, dann wird es halt tricky irgendwann, weil dann schaffst du mehr pro Tag, musst du dann länger schlafen pro Tag, wie sieht es aus dem Kalender?
Das ist ja spannend.
Das ist furchtbar.
Wenn der Tag 25 Stunden, also eigentlich dürfte sich ja nichts verändern. Weil in manchen Ländern ist ja mehr dunkel. Aber es gibt ja dann weniger Tage pro Jahr, oder nicht? Genau. Also ich finde gut, wie es gerade ist, aber warum findet man es gut, wie gerade ist? Ja gut, du bist ja natürlich darauf eingepolt. Das ist eine sehr spannende Frage, weil in manchen Ländern ist ja mehr dunkel zum Beispiel. Ich glaube, es ist so schnell. Also wenn man überlegt, in Norwegen gibt es ja vier Tage. In manchen Ecken wird es ja lange nicht hell. Oder ist es überhaupt ein Tag oder war das jetzt ein lange? Oder geht die Sonne nicht unter? Ja. Alles berechtigte Fragen. Ich glaube, es war so schnell, wie der Fingernagel wächst, so schnell entfernt sich der Mond. Zufall? Ja. Ja, ist ein Zufall. Es gibt schon viele Zufälle. Aber ungefähr so die gleiche Geschwindigkeit, oder wie so ein Haar wächst oder eins von beiden. Warum trauen Menschen dem Zufall nicht? Menschen wollen immer alles in geordnete Bahnen lenken. Aber es ist manchmal einfach ein Zufall. Ja, absolut. Ja genau, aber Menschen trauen dem nicht. Menschen trauen Zufall nicht über den Weg. Ja, das stimmt. Du meinst so wie du damals. Hast du mittlerweile eigentlich schon erfahren, ob du dein Haus gewonnen hast? Nein, ich habe es noch nicht. Du hast letzte Woche ja gesagt, du hast teilgenommen bei der großen Lostombola. Ich glaube, das dauert noch bis November. Ich glaube, das dauert noch bis November. Bis November. Ja, ich glaube, du kannst das die nächsten Folgen das Thema sparen. Das heißt, im November, wenn du plötzlich sagst, ah, besuch mich mal an der Grenze zu Belgien, dann sage ich, Moment mal, weil du wärst glaube ich so jemand, der würde niemanden von seinem Gewinn erzählen. Wenn du im Lotto gewinnst und dann sagst du, kommst du da an. Wie würde es merken? Wie würde es subtil? Was wären die Hinweise, dass du plötzlich sehr reich wärst? Exaltierte Kleidung. Ja, also mit Schulterpolstern, Umhang, Krone. Ich denke mir wirklich, ich wäre so gut reich. Ich denke mir, manchmal denke ich mir eigentlich, allein von den Skills verdiene ich mehr Geld. Also ich sollte mehr Geld haben. Nicht wegen Skills, ich verdiene mehr Geld, weil ich mit dem Geld besseres Zeug machen würde. Ich hätte ein schöneres Haus, die würde das Schöne einrichten. Reiche haben oft keinen Geschmack, wie sie sich einrichten. Das ist einfach so zusammengeworfene Willkürlichkeit, alles zu nehmen, weil es ja eh überflutzt ist, eh alles da, fließen keine Gedanken mehr rein. Aber das ist so, oder die Art Autos, die sie sich kaufen oder die Uhren. Also du würdest besser konsumieren und mehr Stil. Ich wäre viel besser darin, mein sehr viel Geld gut anzulegen. Okay. Das ist in meinen Augen. Also, falls ihr Geld übrig habt, schickt es Stefan. Ihr könnt es gut anlegen, auch einfach in gewisse Leute. Wenn ihr reich seid, würde ich gerne mal so einen Switcheroo machen, so für einen Monat. Einfach mal so, ihr lebt mein Leben, ich lebe das superreiche Leben. Und die Person ist dann auch im Podcast hier.
Meinetwegen. Ich möchte einfach nur mal einen Monat mal so ein Geldspiel-keine-Rolle-Konto haben, wo ich mal einfach, äh Geldspiel-keine-Rollex und dann so wirklich rumlaufen und es genau so konsumieren, wie ich es will. Ich glaube, ich wäre besser darin.
Aber wenn du jetzt im Lotto gewinnst, dann gibt es ja dann immer so dieses, ah, ich sage es niemandem, aber es gibt gleichzeitig dieses Event, wo man das abholt. Und dann kommen da manche Leute, aber dann auch vermummt und so. Also was ist das für eine merkwürdige Situation? Du musst dir ja das Geld abholen, da bist du ja noch nicht reich, da bist du ja noch einfach nur ein Typ mit einem Leitzordner, den er sich vor ins Gesicht hält und dann hast du aber ganz viel Geld und kannst natürlich dich undercover untertauchen, so wie du willst, aber bis zu dem Moment musst du das schon noch aushalten, dass die Leute sehen, wer du bist, wer kommt zu so einer, also sagt er, habt ihr gehört, der Gewinner für den Jackpot wurde festgelegt, wollen wir nach Bottrop fahren, um den zu sehen? Ja, um uns damit anzufreunden. Nee, eigentlich nicht. Nö. Ach, du meinst, da ist dann so eine Reihe an Bittstellern, die dann da irgendwie so, oh mein Kind hat Ausschlag. Wir kommen aus dem fernen Bottrop und wir bringen Mürre. Ja, nee, ich habe gerade 300 Millionen gewonnen. Sorry, nee, lass mir die Mürre. Wir bringen Mürre und dieses, die Newton-Kugeln.
Das ist nett, brauche ich gerade nicht. Ich habe 300 Millionen Euro gewonnen. Ich brauche nichts, gar nichts.
Irgendwer hat ja 9-11 im Lotto gewonnen.
An dem Tag meinst du?
Ich bin immer noch bei dem Kostüm, weil ich mir denke, da ist ja noch mehr Traum passiert.
Hat jemand 9-11 gewonnen und sich gefreut oder dann genau und dann hast du so einen megacoolen Tag ja, aber halt die Welt nicht, ja, ja und du willst es teilen mit Leuten und sagst die ganze Zeit so Leute, ich habe übrigens ein Lotto gewonnen, alle so, ja, ich sage mal auf mit deinem Thema, wir gucken gerade wieder. Ja, die werden den kompletten Tower wieder aufbauen müssen. Was wird das kosten? Viele, viele Millionen wird das kosten.
Wo sollen die das Geld hernehmen, den kompletten Tower wieder aufzubauen und das alles aufzuräumen?
Wenn ich jetzt reich wäre, würde ich alles spenden, den Opfern und Angehörigen.
Ja, ich glaube, ich würde alles der Feuerwehr und der Polizei und den Nothelfern spenden.
Die sind die wahren Helden heute.
Das sind die wahren Helden, die verdienen das Geld.
Und dann gehen alle Köpfe so langsam zu einem.
Und du einfach mit so einer goldenen Zigarre einfach.
Hm?
Na, ist ja auch viel steuer, ne?
Also ist ja auch viel mit dem, ähm, mit dem Steuerding.
In der Zigarre ist so eine kleine Klappe drin, wo genau auf der richtigen Höhe dann auch noch Koks mitgenommen werden kann, tatsächlich. Aber du kannst ja auch Goldstaub schnupfen kannst du auch, also es geht auch ganz geil eigentlich. Und hast du schon gespendet an die Angehörigen? Ähm, ach shit, das, ja, da hatte ich einen Termin, aber da stand ich im Stau leider mit dem, mit meinem neuen Padmobil.
Das nimmt drei Spuren an. Ach shit, das, ja, da hatte ich einen Termin, aber da stand ich im Stau leider mit dem, mit meinem neuen Badmobil.
Das nimmt drei Spuren ein.
Ja, das nimmt leider drei Spuren ein und dann stehst du da eine Weile.
Und mein Chauffeur meinte dann, das wird lange dauern und dann habe ich es nicht mehr zu dem Spenden-Ding geschafft.
Du meinst das Kinderheim mit dem Dinosaurier, der da die Süßigkeiten verteilt.
Habe ich es nicht geschafft, leider. Habe ich es nicht geschafft. Ja, irgendwer hat ja dann so einen Heiratsantrag gemacht, morgens noch oder so. Ja. Am spätabends, am zehnten. Und das dann gefilmt und dann, ja. Und dann willst du es halt feiern. Also ist wahrscheinlich schon mehr noch am Rande passiert, was es vielleicht mal lohnt.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, viele hatten wahrscheinlich auch ein unangenehm, also angenommen, du hattest ein Date für den 11. September und du hast am Tag gemerkt, ich habe eigentlich keinen Bock drauf, bin ich gut drauf, ich habe irgendwie Durchfall, eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock drauf, eigentlich will ich mit Menschen eigentlich nichts zu tun haben, soll ich das Date absagen, nicht und dann stellst du den fernseher und denkst halleluja halleluja halleluja aber muss man dann extra noch absagen oder oder ist es automatisch abgekänzelt du siehst es ja gerade kommt dann die nachricht und denkt so halleluja die nachricht ist du siehst es ja gerade, kommt dann die Nachricht und man denkt so, Halleluja! Moment, die Nachricht ist, du siehst es ja gerade. Aber die Vorstellung ist, dass man gar keine Möglichkeit hat und man betet und sagt, lieber Gott, ich möchte da nicht hingehen, ich möchte da nicht hingehen. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, es gab das Kind, es gab den Kevin, der hat einen Test, an dem Tag hat er einen Test, hat nicht gelernt, hat auch vergessen, hat keine Zeit, weil das Baseballspiel wichtiger war als Quarterback Quarterback. Und dann morgens setzt er sich ans Bett und sagt, fuck, fuck, fuck, bitte Gott, lass irgendwas. Lass einfach nur die Schule ausfallen. Und in dem Moment hört man so, und er kommt aus dem Fenster, sieht das World Trade Center und er denkt sich so, holy shit. Er schaut und in der Sonne sieht er noch so Jesus, der ihm so zublinzelt. Oh mein Gott, was habe ich getan?
Und dann denkst du halt, du bist hardcore mächtig, Gott ist grausam, Gott ist tot, Teufel ist an der Macht. Ja. Das ist schon auch wahrscheinlich schlimm. Da gibt es bestimmt Geschichten. Menschen, die denken, sie wären schuld. Oder es gibt ja auch so ein bisschen abergläubige Menschen, die jeden Abend, weiss nicht, müssen sie die Wand genau da an dem Lichtschalter nochmal berühren oder sowas. Oder ich habe es oft bei Flugzeugen, ich muss die außen berühren. Und dann denke ich mir auch so, wenn ich abstürze, denke ich mir so, ja, habe ich vergessen, das ist meine Schuld, ich bin schuld an allem. Ja, oder es stürzt ab und du hast es trotzdem angefasst und dachtest dir, ach, es liegt nicht an mir, zum Glück. Ich habe getan, was ich konnte. Ach Gott sei Dank. Ich habe wirklich getan, was ich konnte. Ich habe das Omen wirklich so manipuliert, wie es nur geht. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor Omen. Hast du ein schlechtes Omen schon mal gesehen? Irgendwie so dunkle Wolken oder irgendwie... Katze, schwarze Katze. Schwarze Katze oder dass irgendwie so ein Blutfleck so Blut von der Decke tropft, genauso auf deinen Namen, auf irgendeinem Dokument oder so und du denkst dir, ist das ein schlechtes Zeichen oder was soll ich da machen? Oh, ich hab Nasenbluten, denke ich dann. Aber ja, das finde ich interessant. Also es gibt vermutlich wirklich, dass bei solchen Events so Randphänomene, wie zum Beispiel das Kind, was Zeit seines Lebens Angst hat, das ausgelöst zu haben. Oder du isst so einen Käse mit so Löchern drin, du isst ein Sandwich, du liest gerade ein Buch, Käse fällt runter und durch das Loch sieht man genau Tod einfach. Und dann hast du Remoulade im ganzen Nietzsche-Buch und dann ist das auch ein schlechtes Zeichen.
Kann alles passieren.
Würdest du dein Leben stark ändern oder ist dann der Gag, dass
gerade dadurch, weil du dein Leben so stark
änderst, dann stirbst du?
Wenn du Angst vor der Zukunft hast,
dann kriegst du die Zukunft. Das Final Destination Problem.
Es ist final,
da kannst du nichts machen.
Das stimmt schon. Ja, da ist doch auch so ein bisschen so,
du erfahrtest den Tod und dann trotzdem
kommst du immer wieder. Der sucht dich halt so heim, dass du dich
dann trotzdem wieder in Situationen wiederfindest, wo der Tod
Und Da kannst du nichts machen. Das stimmt schon. Ja, da ist doch auch so ein bisschen so, du erfahrtest den Tod und dann trotzdem kommst du immer wieder. Der sucht dich halt so heim, dass du dich dann trotzdem wieder in Situationen wiederfindest, wo der Tod um die Ecke lautet. Lauter der nicht eh, habe ich recht. Ja, ja. Ich glaube, da gab es, es gibt ja auch die Negativbeispiele. Irgend so ein Typ, der war in Hiroshima, dann ist die Bombe gefallen und der sagt, dass ich fuck raus hier und ist in eine andere Stadt gefahren, nach Nagasaki und wurde nochmal getroffen. Hast du zwei Mal überlebt. Da denkst du dir auch, die haben es auf mich abgesehen, warum bin ich denen so wichtig, warum bin ich denen so wichtig, ich bin nicht kriegsentscheidend. Und er fährt weg und die Bomben hinter ihm. Ja, das sind alles wahre Geschichten, das ist alles passiert. Ja klar, bei solchen grossen Ereignissen, die so viele Menschen betreffen, kann ich mir vorstellen. Auch hier wieder Zufall akzeptiert den Zufall. Kommen natürlich auch dann wieder Verschwörungstheorien, die dann sagen, ja, ich glaube nicht an Zufall, da kann nichts Zufall sein und dann entsteht sowas. Und dann diskutierst du da noch ewig rum. Weil ist da eigentlich der meistgesuchte Sterbe. Ja, der sollte eigentlich ausgeschaltet werden, weil der ist der Zeitenläufer, der die Prophezeiungen aus der Zukunft bringt und sowas. Genau, Baby Hitler tötet. Gibt es aktuelle Prophezeiungen eigentlich?
Also es gab ja die Mormonen, die ja meinten, eines Tages fliegen alle mit Jesus weg.
Auf seinen neuen Planeten.
Auf den neuen Planeten.
Genau.
Dann der Maya-Kalender gab es ja eine ganze Zeit lang.
Und gibt es noch laufende, also ich hätte gerne eine Website, wo aktuell laufende Prophezeiungen.
Ah ja. Also ein Kind wird geboren, das schneller schwimmen kann als ein Oktopus und das den Antichrist besiegen wird. Oder irgendwie, es wird eines Tages ein Apfel gewachsen, der dreimal so groß wie alle anderen Äpfel und der die Sünde. Es gibt eine Seite, merko.de. Nostradamus-Prophezeiung für 2024. Alter, wie viel hat der denn vorausgesagt? Hat der keine Hobbys? Wie viel hat Nostradamus vorausgesagt?
Also, die Prophezeiung des Nostradamus im Überblick. Erstens Papst Franziskus, Russlands... Was? Wie? Naja, der Papst Franziskus wird sterben. Woher wusste Nostradamus davon? Immerhin war es 2023. Immerhin, Papst Franziskus ist nicht wie vorhergesagt 2023 zurückgetreten, an seiner Stelle wurde auch kein bedrohlicher Führer das Oberhaupt der katholischen Kirche. Nach übereinstimmenden Berichten von Bild.de, Sat.1.de und Österreich 24, er sagt Nostradamus, die haben direkt einen Kontakt an sich, nun dessen Tod für 2024 voraus. Moment, was ist das jetzt? Don't ask question. Durch den Tod eines sehr, sehr alten Papstes wird jemand in einem guten Alter gewählt, soll Nostradamus geschrieben haben.
Papst Franziskus wird am 17. Dezember 87 Jahre alt. Er leidet aktuell unter gesundheitlichen Problemen, das stimmte. Putin erwartet laut Nostradamus einen Tanz mit dem Schicksal. Zweifel am Nostradamus, der Milos besagt, Michel de Nostredame sollte so unter anderem Napoleon, Hitler und sogar den 11. September prophezeit haben, und doch lag er noch öfter daneben. Wie Simpsons ja auch. Das stimmt, ja das stimmt. Die Der Historiker und Nostradamus-Experte Jörg Dendl ordnete die Prophezeiung aus dem Jahr 1555 im Spiegelinterview vor 20 Jahren ein.
Die Verse sind so unklar, dass man vieles hineininterpretieren kann, ähnlich wie bei Horoskopen auch. Ob Nostradamus überhaupt ein Astrologe war? Selbst daran gibt es große Zweifel. Wofürgings steht, okay, also debunkt, merco.de einfach Nostradamus, Fakt, Fakt, Fakt, Fakt, Merco eins, Nostradamus null. Ja. Schade, aber dass sich auch seit 500 Jahren niemand mehr hinsetzt und mal so eine ordentliche Prophezeiung raushaut. Wir haben das gemacht. Wir haben das gemacht, ja, aus Versehen Corona vorhergesagt. Ja, und ich meine Kopfhörerchen. Ja, und du deine Kopfhörer, ja, es ist, es waren unterschiedliche Prophezeiungen, aber ich finde so Nostradamus, dass der der einzige ist in der Geschichte der Menschheit, der mal wirklich was rausgehauen hat, der mal einfach mal eine Ansage macht, der nicht, ja, vielleicht könnte ja KI in der Zukunft noch mehr eine Rolle spielen, weil ja so, sondern einfach sagen, nein, am 8.8.2028 stirbt der Papst. so, hat jemand was gesagt? Hat jemand was gesagt? Gesagt? Den Papst eingesagt? Am 5. April 2034 wird eine Brücke einstürzen. Stefan, Stefan, wach auf! Stefan, du warst gerade kurz weg, oder? Du hast was gesagt, aber du hast gesprochen in Trance, wie in Trance.
Was hab ich denn gesagt?
Du hast wie in Trance gesprochen.
Ja, was hab ich gesprochen in Trance, wie in Trance. Was habe ich denn gesagt? Du hast wie in Trance gesprochen. Ja, was habe ich denn in Trance gesagt? Du hast gesagt, dass eine Brücke einstürzen wird. Das habe ich jetzt nicht mehr in Erinnerung. Oh mein Gott! Ja, das ist nämlich auch, man muss nämlich auch nie da nicht erschrecken. Oh oh, die Glocken! Die Glocken des Herrn! Die Glocken von Köln! Die Glocken von Köln! Die Domstadt am Rhein. Das sind die, ihr hört nicht die Glocken des Kölner Doms, leider, leider, da können wir uns noch keinen, weil wir eben nicht reich sind. Ja, die klingen leider anders. Aber auch hier, wenn ich reich wäre, würde ich sagen, ich fände es geil, ein Büro direkt am Kölner Dom, sogar im Kölner Dom. Ach, aber würdest du neue Glocken in dem Dom spielen? Nein, da hatte ich neulich tatsächlich eine richtig geile Erfahrung mit reingegangen, habe es Leuten statt fremden Leuten gezeigt und habe denen Führung gegeben durch den Kölner Dom am Heiligen Drei Königsschrein. Ist dir gerechtigt überhaupt, eine Führung zu geben durch den Kölner Dom? Nein, ich gehe einfach rein und sage Hallo und dann grüssen die mich mit Namen und auf tiefen Verbeugungen. Aber du als Sankt Stephan bist ja durchaus auch gern gesehen, du bist ja dann religiöser Leitstern quasi. Du bist ein Mickey Maus im Disneyland. Und dann musst du wieder Kinder segnen und alles und so, ja. Naja, jedenfalls da war richtig schwierig mit reingegangen und in dem Moment ging die Orgel an. Und das war wirklich so ein Sankt Moment, wo ich dachte, oh, das ist vielleicht das nächste Wunder. Jetzt kann ich, was ich vollbracht habe. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Wir kriegen ganz viele Nachrichten zu dem Jesus-Influencer. Ja. Zu dem Influencer, der heilig gesprochen wurde, der ist aber tot. Man kann nur heilig gesprochen werden, wenn man tot ist. Und der hat einige Wunder begangen und die wurden jetzt auch abgesegnet vom Vatikan und der ist jetzt offiziell heilig gesprochen als Influencer, Heiliger. Also es gibt immer noch Möglichkeiten, heilig gesprochen zu werden. Du kannst aber zu Lebzeiten nur selig gesprochen werden. Ja, selig reicht mir, bin ich ja gar nicht so. Müsstest du, das ist dein, also dein erstes Wunder war, du hast einen Fünf-Euro-Schein bei zwei Kindern gleichermaßen geteilt. An Sankt Martin. Ich habe an Sankt Martin zwei Kindern fünf Euro gegeben und denen gesagt, wie sie es uns unterteilen sollen. Gut, das war Wunder eins. Wunder zwei war, du bist in Kölner dumm gegangen und in dem gleichen Moment hat die Orgel angefangen zu spielen. Ja, Wunder drei ist, ich habe einer Frau den Rollstuhl die Treppe runtergetragen, in der Kölner U-Bahn. Was du gar nicht hättest tun müssen. Und dann Wunder vier ist, ich habe einem, auf dem Markusplatz in Venedig, habe ich jemandem, einem Engländer, einen Reiseführer hinterhergetragen. Oh Gott, ey, ich hoffe, ich weiß nicht, wie deine Statue aussehen würde, das ist einfach, es sind einfach zu viele, auch zu viele Gimmicks irgendwie einfach, Du hast nicht so ein grosses Ding. In verschiedene Richtungen. Ja. Aber Jesus hat auch viel gemacht, ne? Es ist ja auch nicht, dass er so ein grosses Ding gemacht hat, sondern er hat ja auch irgendwie hier mal da, da mal ein paar Sachen gemacht. Hier mal übers Wasser, da mal Brot geteilt. Die Auferstehung war schon relativ gut dabei. Hier mal Wasser zu Wein gemacht. Aber ansonsten auch eher so kleine Gimmicks oder so. Wenn er über Wein gegangen wäre, wenn er über Wein gegangen wäre. Erste Wasser zu Wein gemacht hätte und dann über Wein gegangen wäre. Und dann über Wein, Brot teilend über Wein. Da wäre ich sofort kommentiert. Judas, Judas, hör mal auf, du fängst ja wieder an, davon zu reden. Ich habe doch nur Wasser getrunken. Judas, du fängst schon wieder an.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, auf, du bist nicht der, ich ... Es ist jetzt vorbei, Judas, du fängst schon wieder damit an, immer diese Themen. Ich hab nur Wasser getrunken heute Abend, du bist gar nicht Gottes Sohn. Du bist ein elender Verrät. Sandmann, lieber Sandmann, ist es noch nicht so ein. So schlief Judas ein und konnte Jesus nie verraten, denn Jesus wusste um Judas Verrat und hat vorsichtshalber das ganze Wasser im Bauch von Judas in Wein verwandelt. Woraufhin er starb an einer … Auf dreissig Zentimeter Distanz konnte er das tun und hat genau getroffen und dann wurde Judas schläferig und betrunken, obwohl er keinen Alkohol getrunken hatte an dem Tag. Und so lebte Jesus ein langes, langes Leben bis ins tiefe Alter und er starb nie, er starb an Altersschwäche, dann an einem herrlichen Frühlingsabend in Düsseldorf. Ende. Das ist das Florentine-Evangelium, das sich aktuell, also das sich gerade stark promotet. Es hat einen Hang zum Kitsch und zum Happy Ending. Ja, aber es ist eine Alternativversion, es ist historische Fanfiction, nenne ich das Ganze. Und das könnt ihr ab jetzt erwerben. Ganz anders als die Bibel, wie fakten treu ist. 24,99, Klettkotter erschienen. 24,99. Ja, es sind saftige 160 Seiten. Aber Hardcover, Hardcover, Hardcover, Hardcover, Hardcover. Ja, Hardcover braucht niemand. Hardcover ist teuer. Das ist wertig, Hardcover ist wertigig und das ist auch recht teuer im Druck. Deswegen bestellt es gerne unter halleluja mit vier L. Und drei R am Ende, halleluja. Ja, da waren erstaunlich viele Domains schon weg, aber ich habe es geschafft. .de? .vat, ist alles unter Vatikan noch, damit es ein bisschen heiliger ist. Aber macht das, holt euch eine Kopie ab, solange es noch welche gibt.
Es gibt noch genug.
Aber ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder, wenn es der Herr will.
Und dann setzen wir uns wieder zusammen an die Tafel.
Wir sitzen immer noch am Strand an der Côte d'Azur.
Und jetzt lassen wir diesen Abend herrlich ausklingen mit ein paar persönlichen Anekdoten,
auch unserer Gäste, die bis jetzt noch gar nichts gesagt haben.
Lassen wir die auch mal zu Wort kommen. Ich würde sagen, wir schnüren uns mal den Mund zu und geben das Wortgefallen. Es ging ja da kurz um den Tod, um nochmal klar durch den Schrecken des Todes Bild hervor. Verstehe, also ein Symbol, das aber erst nur interpretiert wird. Und dahinter, ist das ein UFO dahinter? Ja, da steigen wir jetzt auch einen.
Ach Gott, okay, dann lassen wir mal die anderen reden.
Dann nehmen wir uns alle anhand der Menschenkette.
Alle halten sich an der Hand und wir steigen alle rein ins UFO.
Alles klar, kommt rein.
Der letzte macht Tür zu.
Reden weiter, tschüssi, wir little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, little, Zusatzauslosung gibt es bis 18. Mai täglich extra Gewinne, einen Audi Q2 und 530 mal 100 Euro in bar.
Keno, die tägliche Zahlenlotterie, in jeder Lotto-Annahmestelle und auf Lotto-Bayern.de.
Lotto Bayern, nimm dein Glück in die Hand.